hello friends of c4 we are truly living
as you all know in unprecedented and
very challenging times right now
so i wanted to connect with you
virtually in this more personal way than
just reading
one of my president's messages and i
want to assure you that we have been
extremely busy
over the last few months engaged i think
in both in meaningful
work meaningful research both in terms
of the short term and dealing with the
pandemic
and in our long-term interest in using
science to address some of the most
important questions
facing science and humanity
i think one of the things one can't help
but notice about this whole pandemic
and how we're going to approach it and
get out of it
is how the centrality of science to
dealing with the pandemic
from the germ theory disease and
physical distancing to washing our hands
to the diagnostics to drug development
to vaccine development to the contact
tracing apps
that are being developed at the moment
all of this is dependent on fundamental
research
and it's interesting to me that none of
it none of it
was developed to deal with covet 19. it
was all developed
to understand the world and that's why
science and
your support for cfar is so important
because that's what we are all about
[Music]
you